Donald Trump has been in office about a
hundred and forty-five days now it's
been scandal after scandal it's
difficult for the average person to keep
up with it and the media has been
covering the scandals and rightly so and
it's interesting to go back and see what
was happening at this point during
Barack Obama's presidency eight years
ago what was he being criticized for and
we went back and looked at and just
about eight years ago it was May of 2009
just over eight years ago when President
Obama was only a few months into his
first term in office President Obama and
Vice President Biden decided to leave
the White House one day and go to a DC
area restaurant for some hamburgers
what's more American than that compared
what's going on with Trump right now
with what you are about to see Fox News
criticizing Barack Obama for doing
putting Dijon mustard on a hamburger
this is because Fox News really had to
reach in order to manufacture right-wing
criticism of the then president this is
in stark contrast to what is going on
right now just a reminder here it is and
finally tonight as you all know
President Obama is a real man of the
people and yesterday he dropped by a
popular Virginia restaurant to grab a
burger with his pal Joe now the Gateway
Putnam plug pointed out that plain old
ketchup well it didn't quite cut it for
the president now take a look at him
ordering his burger with a very special
condiment basic cheddar cheeseburger
medium-well
I like it spicy mustard some like
alright does Jean mustard I think the
president watched it a little bit too
much television as a kid
zombie would you have any Grey Poupon
you mean the mustard yes would you have
any would I or do I this exit alright I
hope you enjoyed that fancy burger mr.
president so at this time in his
presidency really at any time during his
presidency President Barack Obama wasn't
under investigation for collusion with a
foreign adversary and the potential
cover-up of that collusion Obama's
national security adviser wasn't having
to resign because of meetings with said
for an adversary Obama wasn't
inappropriately divulging intelligence
secrets to said foreign advertise
versary in the Oval Office
Obama wasn't firing the FBI director
because of an investigation into his own
campaign Obama wasn't trying to ban
people from the country based on their
religion or alienating our NATO allies
Obama wasn't insulting the mayor of an
ally like London after they had a
terrorist attack Obama wasn't tweeting
bizarre things at 4:00 a.m. in the
morning everyday seemingly I could go on
and on Obama was having a normal
presidency so detestable people like
Sean Hannity had to conjure up fake
scandals about the president to find
something negative to say about him
the over-the-shoulder graphic above
Hannity by the way has bottles of
mustard photoshopped next to Obama with
the text president poop on ordering the
wrong mustard was the big fox news Obama
scandal in May of 2009 Dijon gate by the
way spicy mustard on a burger doesn't
really sound bad that besides the point
but maybe I'm biased because being
Jewish I have a predilection for brown
deli spicy and Dijon style mustards is
that possible path yeah I think that's a
fair assessment David and you know I
think Sean Hannity doing this was trying
to play into this idea that Barack Obama
and the Democrats are these big elitist
Hollywood type yeah you take a look at
two
of the most recent Republican presidents
you have a Hollywood actor and you have
a celebrity reality star billionaire
yeah and it's it's totally hypocritical
and listen this is the same network that
has been endlessly defending Donald
Trump through all of his scandals and
mishaps and disasters and under Obama it
was Obama ordered Dijon mustard Obama
wore a tan suit which didn't
appropriately reflect the seriousness of
that day's events and by the way they
slammed Michelle Obama for having a $500
j.crew dress that was too expensive for
the average American meanwhile Melania
Trump is fashionable for wearing a
$50,000 coat no criticism there context
folks what's happening is utterly out of
this world